all right creatures of the internet we
are live i'm dave rubin and we've got
another friday round table extravaganza
for you as always we are live streaming
on blaze tv on rumble and on youtube
although with them you never know
joining me this week is a lawyer and
host of viva barnes law on locals.com
viva frey the host of the news and why
it matters right here on blaze tv sarah
gonzalez and writer for noble truths
with rav arora ravarora viva sarah rav
welcome to the reuben report thanks for
having us hey it's good to be here i
like the rhythm of those names very easy
and soft and good uh obviously guys this
was a completely
wacky week uh you know i try to do my
show as as light as possible and not
make people crazy about politics and
everything else but we got to do some
heavy lifting up top and then hopefully
we can get to some more fun stuff uh
towards the end of the show so look the
big thing of course was the uvalde
shooting in the city in texas 19 kids i
think and two teachers
were killed um i tried up when i covered
it the first day not to do anything
about politics because one of the things
that i mentioned to you guys right
before we started was just watching
everything become immediately political
about
restricting gun rights or defending gun
rights or attacking republicans or
attacking democrats it was like we
didn't even take one second to to talk
about these lives these kids the parents
that sent their kids to school that day
and we'll never see them again
and i felt like we had to kind of sit
with that a little bit but for what we
all do for a living this is about
politics
and i want to start with a little bit of
what's going on in the media related to
all that real quick before i let you
guys chime in i want to talk about
healthy cell
have you guys ever wondered if those
vitamins you're taking every day are
actually working for you well more than
240 million americans take supplements
daily in pill form but they usually
don't get the promised results because
they don't absorb the nutrients properly
what if i told you there's a new type of
dietary supplement one that will absorb
into your body far better i want to tell
you about healthy cell it's a new
ingestible gel that not only tastes
great but has
165 percent more absorption than pills
it uses a new technology called micro
gel to deliver maximum absorption
those old-fashioned tablets capsules and
powders can contain synthetic other
ingredients ever wonder what they are
it's things like binding glues fillers
and coatings that can irritate the
lining of your stomach healthy cells
micro gel on the other hand suspend
soluble ultra absorbable nutrient
particles inside a gel made out of gut
healthy ingredients like soluble fiber
citrus pectin acasia gum and water it
doesn't contain artificial sweeteners
flavorings or colorings it's even
non-gmo gluten free and vegetarian visit
healthycell.com that's c-e-l-l dot com
and use code reuben for 20 off your
first order okay so let's just dive
right into the
political part of uvalde uh i thought
sort of the most shocking thing of the
week was beto o'rourke's uh attack
on greg abbott and some of the other
officials in the town and in the state
of texas let's take a
look excuse me excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
next shooting is right now and you're
doing nothing no he needs to get his ass
out of here this isn't the place to talk
to him this is totally predictable
sir you're out of line
sir you are online i'm sure you are out
of line please leave this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue here
okay so you've got the mayor of uvalde
there you've got the police chief there
obviously senator ted cruz was there the
governor of texas greg abbott was there
and pedro o'rourke who is a charlatan in
my opinion and everything that's wrong
with politics making this about him he
had no right to burst into that press
conference etc uh sarah i want to start
with you because that is texas is your
state and if there's one state hurting
more than any other right now it is
texas um but actually why don't we start
first uh you're you're the mother of two
young children uh why don't we why don't
we do the human part before we dive into
the political part
yeah um
look it my
i wept uh the day that it happened
going through the pictures of all of the
children that were deceased thinking
about you know how similar they look to
my oldest son who is about to be 10 i
mean these are real life human issues
and although statistically speaking our
kids are still
one one of the most safe places for our
children are in schools it just doesn't
feel that way anymore and so it was um
it was hard uh to watch all of this
happen to watch this community grieving
and hurting and still not have answers
for exactly how things happen the way
that they did
and to see
beto o'rourke himself dancing
practically on on the graves of these
murdered children was just really hard
to watch as a as a mother as a texan uh
as someone who is active in the gun
rights community all of these things
right and um you know it was just uh
it's difficult to watch it be
politicized because at the end of the
day the more information that we see
coming out about this particular
incident
really just solidifies the need for
citizens to be able to protect
themselves and their families because
when you leave it in the hands of law
enforcement and government officials
to be to rely on them to protect you
it's not going to work and it's sad to
see this be politicized when really this
is proving the case for us to be able to
defend ourselves and defend our families
and i think if the left had any
integrity they would look at themselves
in the mirror and they would look at the
the the issues that they are
contributing to uh the breakdown of the
family unit the glorification of mental
illness uh the the degradation of young
men in our society the lack of morals
the godlessness in this country they
would look at themselves in the mirror
and say what the hell have we done to
this country and how can we contribute
to bringing back to where we need it
without taking away people's rights to
defend themselves so you actually hit a
whole bunch of stuff that i talked about
this week in terms of family and the
spiritual part of the mental health part
which i want to cover with all of you
guys uh viva because right before we
started you have a couple kids running
around in that house right now that you
were trying to get to be quiet so you
could do this uh just as as a father
watching this
as a human it's incomprehensible tragedy
and and what is what's not it's it's
stomach turning you you don't want to
close your eyes and even think about
what people are going through and then
you go to twitter and you just see
people shamelessly exploiting it i say
like
barack obama put out a tweet they have
they haven't even buried their children
yet and these and these politicians are
weaponizing it exploiting it in
callous and shamelessly political tweets
and before the facts are out we know
that we know the weapon
but the more details that come out now
the more you start to say
you know firearms might be
the weapon being used but there might be
a whole slew of other problems that
might be more directly related to how
this escalated into what it possibly
escalated into and i'm just sitting here
watching it from canada where we have
some of the strictest gun laws in canada
in the world we have a lot of street
violence gun crime on the streets
you take these outlier examples and then
you try to uh weaponize them politically
to make your political points
with total callousness to the human
suffering that's going on behind it um
but the more details that come out about
the police the delay the things i've
heard now
there may be one issue with firearms
that needs to be addressed but there
might be some serious underlying issues
as to how this could conceivably happen
in a school i i've been saying for a
while you have armed security guards at
when you do money drop off at banks you
have armed security guards for venues
it seems that if you want an immediate
solution without without finger pointing
and
security at schools period
and meaningful security but uh people
just jump on this for their political
purposes
i'm sure he believed in what he was
doing but at some point you have to take
a step back and say now is not the time
let people mourn in peace
yeah you're actually giving better a
little more credit than i'm giving him
i'm not sure he knows what he believes
or
or ugh i mean i i just think he wants he
wants attention more than anything else
uh rav you're uh you are wise beyond
your years but you are the youngest on
the panel you graduated high school i
think in 2019 so you're not that far out
of being
being in us he's a young kid he's a
young kid but you're not that far you're
not that far out of being in school and
a lot of this obviously is about school
safety you know you happen to also be up
in canada right now but uh in terms of
just being
being a younger person related to all of
this what's your take yeah yeah and
thanks for highlighting the year i
graduated dave that definitely
is not not something i highlight but
we're just going to talk about it so all
right
i graduated in 94 if that makes you feel
any better
okay grandpa step aside now let me talk
okay
um
listen um the the big thing that i was
thinking about here was the impact that
school closures and virtual learning has
had on young people
for me i go to college i do independent
studies on the side of my journalism
work
and so i've i've seen how virtual
learning can be so like socially
damaging and difficult to
academically um pursue the things that i
want to pursue
but also just just broadly that human
connection that we all need and i saw
with my sister who was in virtual
learning my brother for several months
at a time during cobid
and this individual was already
suffering from
a
an unstable family
his father was an alcoholic he had
issues with his mother at home was not a
good place clearly for him
and once you put him in virtual learning
away from school for for several months
who knows how much that might have
tipped him over and further spiraled him
down this path of fear depression
anxiety loneliness isolation
for a lot of people especially in inner
city communities school
is important because at home there's
there's drugs there's violence there's
abuse and so that connection is
important so for this individual and for
many other individuals and we've seen
homicide rates skyrocket by the way and
i've
written about this in the new york post
the the effects of closing down schools
and going into virtual learning and
instituting like vaccine mandates for
like sports leagues and stuff like that
we're all like doing so much harm to our
youth and to our young people and these
effects we're just beginning to see and
i'm really fearful for what's what's in
the story because we've really damaged a
whole generation of young people and
there's no accounting for that
yeah all right so you hit on a couple
things that i want to bring back to
because it's sort of what sarah was
referencing earlier that this is about
much more than the guns or the murders
themselves because there's a cascade of
issues here so let's just put beto's
intentions aside for a second sarah
before you mentioned family you
mentioned mental health you mentioned
what's happening to young men and a
spiritual crisis i think what rav's
referencing there related to young
people in schooling is all of that i
mean it seems to me we had almost no
discussion about that why i i barely
tweeted this week because i was just
like
watching everybody do what betto did on
twitter everyone immediately you don't
spend or you spend an iota of a second
on the deaths
you know i made a point of showing all
the pictures of those kids because i
want people to actually be affected by
it uh but we have much bigger issues
here that to me can't really be solved
by politics
yeah uh of course and i mean i would
also add into the equation the the
just the devaluing of human life itself
i mean we have an entire party at least
their leaders who are trying to convince
this generation that it is their basic
human right to be able to kill their
baby
up until the point that it comes out of
the magical birth canal so at what point
do you stop and
say why would these people care about
human life itself when we are telling
them that you can throw it away if it
becomes inconvenient to you i mean they
are drilling this into children's heads
they are drilling this into the next
generation should we be surprised that
there is uh this this regard for human
life i i don't think that i don't think
that we can be shocked or surprised that
that this is happening and i'll tell you
this too dave i mean you know you hear
stories of my parents my grandparents
they traveled to school with rifles in
the back of their pickup truck there
weren't school shootings to the degree
that there are now but again i don't
think that the lawmakers want to look at
those particular facts because
then that would shed light on the fact
that this isn't a gun problem this is a
mental health problem this is a
spiritual problem this is really i
really truly believe dave we are at the
place where this is a battle of good and
evil that is where we're at and it's
really difficult to see uh which side is
going to uh is gonna win on that right
now so viva as i said on the show this
week and as many people obviously point
out you could have all the weapons of
war if i had every weapon known to man
in front of me i wouldn't walk into a
school or a church or a synagogue or
anywhere else and kill people so that
shows you that it's not about the weapon
it's about the person who uses the
weapon their mental state spiritual
state et cetera what is is the issue
really that because politics can't deal
with that
and we do everything through a political
lens that that's why this conversation
is so screwy
i i i think so tim poole i don't know if
it's his analogy he had a good one which
is you know you can run someone over
with your car at any minute of the day
you don't walk around the street fearing
everyone driving a vehicle the issue is
these types of incidents are so
traumatizing they're so horrific that
i say even though they amount for a
fraction of the total gun violence in
the states or or anywhere for that
matter they're so traumatizing it's like
the you know an airplane crashing versus
a car accident one is statistically
exponentially more significant than the
other but one traumatizes a nation more
than the other the issue here is that
these are such politicized issues
already people
they don't want a solution they want
their solution and i i've been saying
you're like just practically speaking
i'm from canada we have the strictest
gun laws you know among out there in the
states whether you like it or not you
have 380 some odd million firearms
already out there 70 somewhat million
rifles i believe even if you snapped
your fingers today and said no more
sales we're going to raise the age you
still have a pr you still have a problem
if you think the firearms are the
problem uh the reality is you have soft
target problems you have a phenomenon
now where the media comes out spends a
week glorifying these monsters so that
other people who want to make their name
now you know they have their charts and
they want to get to the top of the chart
literally and the media does it they
know it and it exacerbates the problem
as far as i'm concerned it just security
at the schools if it were so costly for
schools to let these things happen they
would find a solution tomorrow the
bottom line is it's been so politicized
they don't want the good solution they
just want their solution yeah well said
and by the way i'm glad none of you have
mentioned the shooter's name i went out
of my way not to say it this week i
don't want to give him any of the
attention we played a clip of jordan
peterson on my show a couple years ago
talking about the sort of desire
for fame the desire for attention that
drives so much of this rav before i
throw back to you i want to show this
clip just to talk about how the media
just cannot deal with anything honestly
here is the view and i always warn my
audience before i play a clip of the
view
just sit back don't fall out of your
seat here we go if you need to take a
drink this is the time to do it this is
the view sunny hostin defending beto
while also confusing some things about
laws in texas
they seem angrier at better or work than
they were at the massacre of 19 children
and two fourth grade teachers they were
yelling at him i'd like to see some of
that energy around gun safety i was so
shocked
that they were so angry at what he was
saying and he was saying the right
things it was totally predictable i mean
governor abbott is the person that
changed the age of owning a a gun from
21 to 18.
okay so first off i want to clarify
something what she said there was a
complete lie complete fabrication and
live from cbs news i've got it right in
front of me abbott said wednesday after
the uvalde shooting that quote the
ability of an 18 year old to buy a gun
to buy a long gun has been in place in
the state of texas for more than 60
years so she's not only defending the
ridiculous uh outburst by beto but then
also just lying
rav this just happens every day on these
shows and people then are just confused
about what the issues are who the good
guys are and everything else
yeah it's it's really amazing how in in
almost every issue you see this again
and again with the blm stuff which was
kind of
how i started
in my journalistic career writing about
many of these big shootings like jacob
blake um and ray shard brooks atlanta
and many other cases it's like this
happens again and again where you have a
high profile case and usually
the the issue for the left becomes
the racial element so if it's a white
police officer shooting a black
suspect you see immediately like facts
are just totally thrown out
in favor of this precondition narrative
here we're seeing it again with these
details i mean it's like the view is
completely unwatchable to me it's like
every time i see a clip like for my own
mental health i just i can't watch it
because it's so
infuriating constantly to see them
spew this misinformation over and over
again it's like like this is the reason
why people are listening to this right
now dave and people are listening to
joe rogan and wondering why he's so
popular this is why cnn plus
is is in the graves r.i.p um
it's it's like because the mainstream
media is just so bad at covering the
facts they're so
disingenuous that independent media is
rising so i think i think in many ways
that is a good thing is that they're
just openly
spewing this misinformation so that in
individual people who
know how to think can actually detect
that and listen to better media and
hopefully you're watching this show
right now well to your point on what
they cover and what they don't cover 46
people were shot in chicago this weekend
six of them fatally now of course the
reason the media doesn't cover it is
because
the color of the skin of the shooters
and the color of the skin of the victims
doesn't fit the narrative so they don't
cover that and as a matter of fact i
don't know if you guys saw it but in
that very press conference greg abbott
addressed that he said well you know
because of course they're going after
him about gun laws in texas he said well
you do know that in new york and chicago
and in california they have much
stricter gun laws and people are being
shot all the time i wish it wasn't the
case and then of course new york times
wrote an article that he's race-baiting
by even saying that uh so i want to get
to some of the reaction of the left
because surprise surprise they want some
more laws around this but real quick let
me talk to you guys about real estate
agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment i know it is for me and
that's a lot of responsibility so you
need an agent who takes that seriously
that's why i recommend real estate
agents i trust we work with only the
best agents in every market and do our
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join our network and
here's a big one we only work with
full-time professionals no part-time or
inexperienced agents our team makes an
intro and then follows you through the
buying or selling process to make sure
that you're satisfied the agents we work
with have a long track record and are
the best sellers in their field they're
part of this audience the company was
started by my buddy glenn beck himself
they share your values and they're
almost anywhere you want to go including
florida and viva is a new floridian the
process is simple just go to real estate
agents itrust.com today and provide them
with some basic info our team will
contact you to make an intro to our
preferred agent in your town and now
back to me okay so the the main reaction
to this especially from the left is if
we just had more laws
that somehow that would stop this stuff
now we have laws about murder we have
laws about shooting people we have laws
about breaking into people's homes and
attacking people and all sorts of things
but they seem to think just more laws
would stop this um here is adam
kinzinger who believe it or not is a
republican but he basically is a
democrat um and he's talking about
raising the age of the purchase of a
firearm we just raise the age of
purchasing cigarettes for god's sakes to
21. the age of buying alcohol is 21. i
think the age to buy a gun should be 21.
and people can come to me with all the
caveats about well they can serve in the
military i'll say the same thing about
drinking beer by the way between the age
of 18 and 21.
okay i wanted to play this clip because
every now and again someone who i don't
agree with on anything says something
somewhat sane and the idea that you
can't vote but you can go to the
military we have these odd
inconsistencies 18 to do this 21 to do
this get a gun at 18 but can't buy a
beer i mean some of this makes
absolutely
no sense uh rav let me start with you on
this i mean the the odd inconsistencies
uh i know you're canadian but from an
american pre or give me from a canadian
perspective too i'm not even fully sure
on all of your age stuff there
yeah yeah the restrictions are are much
different here for for drinking it's
um
i feel like i should know this but you
usually you don't follow these rules
when you're in high school i'll have my
guys check what's the age what's the age
limit on drinking in canada we'll get
that for you in a sec go ahead
um
but no i i wanted to actually just touch
on one point quickly you said dave
earlier about like gun violence because
this has been the center piece of my
reporting it's like you have all these
laws in blue cities especially but we've
seen homicide rates rise exponentially
like in minneapolis they've risen like
30 percent uh in in la st louis new york
city uh in philadelphia i reported last
year uh in 2020 there were more homicide
deaths than in homicide deaths combined
for 2014 and 2015 that there were more
homicide deaths last year in
philadelphia than two years combined
2014 and 15 and a lot of that was due to
the riots and defunding the police and
all these things that we should be
talking about we should be talking about
having a robust law enforcement response
i think it was ben shapiro who retweeted
this morning
that there was this new detail
that we i think we just found out that
there was no armed response to the
shooter for 12 full minutes after he
crashed his car
okay that's a conversation we should be
having about why that didn't happen we
should be looking at realistic solutions
and actually examining what happened
here and looking at the broader trend of
rising homicidal violence in inner city
communities rather than just
um having these one-sided uh
narrow-minded political conversations
that i think the whole mainstream media
has plunged into yeah and i also think
we have to acknowledge without excusing
anyone who did anything wrong if any of
the officers there did not go in when
they should have and everything else
that there is no such thing as a perfect
system we don't know exactly when people
knew everything we always want the easy
answer like oh this should have happened
at exactly this moment and again that's
not to excuse anyone if anyone acted
negligently but there just aren't always
perfect answers rav just to let you know
uh in canada the drinking age is by
province so where you are in british
columbia it's 19 but it is 18 in quebec
and alberta just fyi if you're looking
to get a drink a little later um okay
sarah referencing i'm 21 i'm 21 so
that's good
but i don't think i was following that
in high school so anyway we don't we
should talk about that noted noted we
won't report you um sarah the this idea
of the 18 to 21. so kinzinger who i'm
sure you're no great fan of either uh
this idea that you can get a gun at 18
but you can't drink to 20 to 21 is
something worth talking about these
inconsistencies there
but you earlier mentioned what's
happening with young men and there
obviously is something happening with
young men right now um for many many
cultural reasons do you think there's
any legitimacy to perhaps raising that
age from 18 to 21
well on the gun side i would say when
yeah yeah i would say that it uh
it becomes a slippery slope issue for me
that um i know what the left wants uh at
the end of the day i know what their end
game is and i think that the second
amendment is very clear even though it
can be uncomfortable at times i would
also argue that they really don't
believe these uh these ideas that people
are too young that that they're still
children that they don't need to have
some sort of uh you know a weapon
because at the end of the day these are
the same people who are weaponizing our
children who are uh telling them that at
three they can change their gender so at
three you're supposed to have the the
knowledge and the foresight and the
wisdom to know what gender and sexuality
you are but somehow at 18 you're not old
enough to know how to use a gun properly
so it's just it's just the
inconsistencies coming from the other
side that i get very uncomfortable
buying into the conversation
again at the end of the day it has to be
a family issue right it's it's these
young men who this this young man was
failed at every level his family life
his friends
all of these people saw these signs and
no one did anything and i think at the
end of the day
your families have to be involved and i
know that that's not always going to
work perfectly as you said there's no
perfect system on either side but
we can't be chipping away at a
fundamental right of this country
because it's going to be a slippery
slope down to the bottom and we know
what uh i would call adam kinzinger
basically the left but we know what
these people in power want and that is
ultimately control they want to be the
only ones with the firearms and so it
just it's i agree with you that like if
we were if we were talking with a a
another party who i believed to be
coming from a a morally sound place
i might be willing to have the
conversation but not with people who
think that you can change your gender at
two or three years old
so speaking of our god-given rights and
the slippery slope uh the night of the
shooting joe biden gave what i think was
one of the worst speeches in american
history it was the most divisive
uh
in many ways dishonest speech possible
there was nothing really about healing
this was the guy who came in and said he
was going to heal the nation we got a
little clip for you i spent my career
as chairman of judiciary committee and
as vice president working for common
sense gun reforms
as i said as a senator and vice
president
although they clearly will not prevent
every tragedy
we know certain ones will have
significant impact and have no
negative impact on the second amendment
second amendment is not absolute
when it was passed you couldn't own a
you couldn't own a cannon
you couldn't own certain kinds of
weapons
it's just always been limitations
okay so first off i want to clarify
something that i slightly butchered
yesterday when we showed this clip yes
you could own a cannon uh when
the second amendment came out you could
own a cannon so that's just number one
so he lied about it
the same way that sonny hosting lied so
i have no problem if i make a mistake
correcting that so there you go for the
record i've corrected that uh
viva the rest of the speech was was
deeply divisive but i want to address
one thing you said there because they
keep saying this over and over common
sense if we just had common sense gun
laws um do you think it's possible that
we don't all agree on what common sense
gun laws are and they're just using a
phrase to confuse us
well i mean it doesn't mean anything it
doesn't mean anything whatsoever but
i wrote down a note because sarah
brought up a good point you know the the
same people arguing for raising the
limit of gun ownership also want to
lower the age limit to vote so they want
to let 16 year olds vote on firearms
issues where they're not allowed owning
firearms by their own logic great point
the alcohol limit you set things
at some point things do become somewhat
arbitrary but what's not arbitrary in
the united states is the second
amendment shall not be infringed and
then the question is what does that even
mean
i you know i'm from canada i took the
firearm safety course in canada i'm from
a country where and by the way just to
correct you dave i'm not a full
floridian yet but i'm certain
as i'm concerned you are um
i took the firearm safety course it was
a two-day course so that i could get a
permit so that i could own a longer to
own a small arm in canada you need a
special permit it's it's and i'm in a
country where they virtually criminalize
gun ownership even when it's lawfully
done i'm in a country where they have
effectively criminalized self-defense
you can't own a firearm for self-defense
you can't own a taser you can't on a
stun gun you can't carry around anything
for self-defense and you're left to the
mercy of the criminals and the response
time of the police and in canada some of
the toughest gun laws anywhere spike in
gun violence because it's not committed
by law-abiding citizens with lawfully
procured firearms
common sense i don't know i i could
support everybody needing to follow a
course before owning a firearm because
it is like driving a car you you are
owning something which can cause serious
destruction for your own safety to go
from there to being registered the
government knowing what you have in your
house where you live criminalizing you
for
political purposes or just you know
other purposes
i've seen that risk as well so i don't
know where you go to find the common
sense middle ground but when common
sense is not being used in a
intellectually honest way it makes it
difficult to have open and honest
dialogue on an issue right that's why
it's so dangerous what he said there he
says common sense which as you said it
doesn't mean anything because we don't
even agree on what that is but then his
next sentence is to say it won't
infringe on the second amendment and
then he lies about the way the second
amendment started and the type of
weapons you could own um let's back up
for a second because there's also this
other uh piece of this i want to show
you this tweet from the washington
examiner
because now they are looking into some
of the inconsistencies in what happened
there can we pull this up from
washington examiner the white house
refused to call for an investigation
into the police response to the school
shooting in uvalde texas saying
president joe biden has the utmost
respect for the men and women of law
enforcement so we referenced this
earlier there seems to be a certain
amount of time that the police did not
go in and that they perhaps were
ignoring orders or there was some
confusion there i think we're all agreed
okay there's no perfect system the fact
that the white house isn't looking into
it this is the same party that wants to
defund the police i mean they usually
hate the police in this case now
something horrific happened and they
don't want to know what happened what's
going on here rev
yeah
yeah i just i just have to say like
utmost respect for law enforcement like
i mean where did that come from yeah
what i mean
when the jacob blake shooting happened
which turned out to be a total
uh misconstrued exaggerated story
wherein he later admitted that he was at
fault for trying to grab
the officer's gun after which he the
officer rightfully shot
you know in that case right away when
that happened kamala harris went over to
see him uh joe biden made this had this
horrible speech about how racist the us
is and how we need to fundamentally
reform law enforcement for this horrible
shooting same thing he did with ray
shard brooks in atlanta another
police shooting which turned out to be
legally justified again there he said
something like
black americans wake up every day
fearing for the police not knowing when
their life could be taken because of the
police like stuff like this that this is
what we're used to so to suddenly see
this back pedal and shift is really
astonishing to me and i don't know what
um
values and what what kind of um
underlying framework biden has for
dealing with these things because it
seems to be
shifting and it seems to matter which
which is most politically expedient
rather than which is the most honest and
factual and compassionate uh take on
these things it almost read to me like
they want everybody to feel like a
conspiracy theorist these days right
like these people who question police
motives and everything that you just
laid out there rav it's like at the same
time this is the one thing that they're
not going to look into this thing that's
all on our mind right now that seems to
be tearing the country in half uh we're
just not going to question their motives
or what happened there just it's very
bizarre uh all right so i do want to end
the week on on some good news because
obviously this story is not going
anywhere but something really good did
happen this week
it started happening last week but it is
official as of this week which is that
the ministry of truth that uh is a was
an insane assault on our first amendment
and shouldn't have even been proposed in
the first place it has completely fallen
apart we've got some info from the new
york post the biden administration has
quote paused its controversial plans to
create a disinformation board
causing its would-be leader to resign in
a statement wednesday nina jankowicz the
disinformation expert tapped to head the
panel said that with the board's work
paused and its future uncertain i have
decided to leave the dhs to return to my
work in the public sphere jankowitz's
departure and the decision to scrap the
board was first reported by the
washington post the board has been the
subject of weeks of backlash from
republicans libertarians and even some
liberals my god they're not all insane
who liken the scheme to the ministry of
truth from george orwell's classical
classic novel 1984. uh guys well maybe
i'm going to start with you first
because even if you're not a floridian
yet you're about to be an american and
uh we have this first amendment thing
here it's defended by that second
amendment thing the fact that this was
even discussed from the people who lie
about everything whether it's the
politicians or the media that lie about
everything
um does that show you we're already down
that path in some ways like we gotta we
we're turning a little bit perhaps but
we've already gone down a very dark path
here
dave i mean it's she's the dis jankowitz
is the disinformation expert but not in
the way that she was using the term i
mean exactly
she was the expert of providing
disinformation uh
it was this it was a stupid idea because
this is it they get so um what's the
word brazen that they start saying the
quiet parts out loud we knew that this
was going on robert barnes and i on our
local channel we've been talking about
this for a long time there there's a
back channel they accidentally mentioned
the back channel between the government
and social media now they just wanted to
front channel the back channel because
they got so confident in their in their
brazenness they say we're just gonna
we're gonna say it publicly when there
are pending lawsuits you know accusing
the government of turning social media
platforms into effectively state agents
and so now they realize holy crap we
might have just formalized what you know
would be a very big problem if indeed
these social media companies these big
tech platforms are in fact effectively
acting as agents of the state because
we're coercing them to do whatever so
they realize i guess a little too late
that they have to backtrack put it on
pause
it was an atrocious idea they were just
getting a little bit too confident in
getting away with it they made it public
what we suspect has been going on for a
while and they got lambasted for it and
rightfully so and also just not to
spread any rumors i'm also not on the
verge of american citizenship yeah but
we'll see what happens in the future
i'm just leading you man i see i see the
future trust me you get a little
sunshine here you hang out with some
iguanas it's all happening uh iguanas
are beautiful they are beautiful rav
tv's point about the back channels that
we knew about i mean i'm sure you saw
the video from a couple months ago when
jen saki admitted that the
administration flags misinformation from
facebook i mean they were already
infringing on our first amendment rights
they were already having some
coordination with companies to limit our
ability to speak uh you're a journalist
we don't really have any journalists
left anymore i mean that i don't have to
go like this you know do the air quotes
um why didn't more journalists you'd
think that journalists might care about
the first amendment why didn't more
journalists say uh maybe we should look
into that that the government telling uh
corporations what can be said on their
platforms is a bit of a problem
yeah yeah well because in their mind
misinformation disinformation dangerous
speech all of these things that they
have sort of an objective criteria for
and and their objective criteria is
anybody that deviates from the
mainstream liberal orthodoxy that is
considered misinformation and we're
talking about vaccines about police
shootings whatever it is
like this thing happens over and over
again um that we see these same patterns
of
censorship i mean with the new york post
story on the hunter biden laptop that
was blocked from sharing on twitter i
mean that is egregious like if you just
read that you would think that that is a
story from like iran or some like
dictatorship or venezuela or something
but that was in the united states that
is deeply
um and also i don't know if you want me
to push a little bit to what's happening
in canada as well like i'm i'm happy
that i'm happy this board is being
dismantling on your side because nina
jankowicz is deliberately um or
or i should say very um disturbing in
nature what what she was uh proposing in
her other weird tic toc videos and
whatnot but here here in canada that
trudeau
is pushing bill c-36 the the online
harms bill that's designed to protect
ethnic minorities sexual minorities
lgbtq
um and and in that bill
what is proposed is that you could
possibly preemptively
report to law enforcement if
one individual thinks that somebody else
is going to say something hateful or
post something offensive you can
preemptively tattletail on them and law
enforcement could
then surveil them for this and and
interestingly enough like this is so
authoritarian it's so sweeping and
um egregious that even twitter has
pushed back on the trudeau government
and has said that this could be used to
silence political opposition um
something very strange for twitter to
say obviously
and even even various ethnic minority
groups here in canada like the canadian
national muslims association has
pushed back against this bill and said
this could actually harm the very groups
that trudeau is trying to pander to with
this bill that's supposedly designed to
protect the feelings of racial and
ethnic minorities because apparently we
can't we can't take pushback online but
it's all just
more and more power in the way of
trudeau that the soul covet pandemic has
just fueled up his his behinds he's got
more and more power and he's trying to
to uh
boost that even more with this online
social media censorship well you know
what folks we are a professional
organization around here so don't take
rav's word for all of that here's justin
trudeau himself
there is no question that the world is
changing rapidly and getting more
dangerous
in new ways than ever before
when we look at the prevalence of
misinformation of disinformation
the way social media has been weaponized
justin trudeau i i can't my friend in
that moment we usually mute everybody we
didn't so i'll let you go first before i
let sarah jump in you just can't deal
with this guy anymore
it's it's audible torture it's
intellectual torture it's outright lies
this guy is now saying he's going to go
after misinformation he has been
responsible for putting out some of the
most egregious misinformation out of his
own mouth some of the most divisive
hateful comments ever he gets on his
podium when he's running for office
talking about the unvaccinated putting
at risk their kids and putting at risk
our kids those people putting us all at
risk he he is what he warns us about and
now he wants laws to basically protect
him and persecute whomever he disagrees
with and whomever he calls
misinformation it's
it's it's outrageous and i mean i'm i'm
glad i'm a reasonably polite person and
didn't say what i was thinking in
anything it's nauseating to listen to
but viva he wears nice socks isn't that
important to you
he
he just it's it's incessant and it's
bill c-36 it's bill c-11 they want to
regulate the internet they basically
want to they want to criminalize any
speech that they don't like and that
happens to be independent media who call
trudeau for what he is
dishonest divisive and ultimately
wickedly unconstitutional
sarah to that point uh this was making
me think back to bill c-16 which of
course you know six or seven years ago
that's the thing that put my good friend
jordan peterson on the map that was the
bill in canada that was being floated
that if you misgendered someone
potentially accidentally if a woman was
walking down the street and dropped her
hat and you accidentally said sir if you
couldn't see their face or whatever it
might be that you could be fined or
potentially even imprisoned that
literally is what put jordan peterson a
mild-mannered psychology professor at
the university of toronto on the map and
you can sort of see a through line
through all of these things he kept
saying at that
it's not going to stop here it's not
going to stop here and now here we are
uh dealing with another bill uh with
another letter and another couple
numbers about misinformation it and i
guess this goes to your slippery slope
point that you were talking about
earlier yeah well i i have a bone to
pick with you too dave because you said
that you were ending on good news and i
don't think that it's good news that
nina jankowicz is now going to be free
to post more tick tock videos during the
day
the singing is horrible you're right
you're right
that is not good news um no i think that
really to to kind of tie it all together
it does go to our original point because
all that misinformation is to all of
these government agencies whether it be
fidel jr whether it be joe biden whether
it be whatever country we're talking
about here all that misinformation is
it's very similar to what what viva was
talking about with common sense gun
reform it doesn't mean anything the word
is meaningless it only means this isn't
the narrative that we choose to spin
therefore we want to tamper down on it
because at the end of the day the
government wants control over everything
they want control over your weapons and
who has them and who doesn't they want
control over your speech they want
control over the narrative they want to
make sure that they maintain that
control and the way to do this is by
chipping away at our second amendment
rights at our first amendment rights at
everything that they have so that they
can maintain that control
i'm gonna have to figure out a way to
end this on a good note without you guys
because this is where we have to say
goodbye as sarah scared the hell out of
everyone uh but sarah viva rav thank you
guys i'll definitely have you back and
have a nice weekend and i'll i'll take
it from there
thank you very much
thanks
thanks dave
all right everybody uh look this was
this was a tough week there's just no
other way around it um
as i said i really had to limit what's
going on on social media even for me
personally because as much as i have to
be in this thing to communicate some of
this stuff to you um
it brought out the worst in almost
everybody and and maybe maybe at moments
myself included i'm not so sure um but i
think as i would always try to say on
the show if we just kind of keep our
heads on straight if we don't just react
you know i think what what they're
trying to do in some ways by talking
about common sense and if we just had
more laws it's just always trying to get
us to react to something so something
bad happen we must react and people who
are not very good at solutions and
usually screw everything up if we just
gave them the power on this one if we
just allowed them to give us the
solution on this one that everything
would be better but i just don't think
things are that easy so i would say more
than anything else uh if you're if
you're feeling a little emotionally
banged up this week or anything else how
about you take the weekend
off this thing i am going to i'm
actually getting a massage in about two
hours uh i've got someone coming over to
the house who's going to massage me i'm
doing a uh deep tissue guys 90 minutes
so you're gonna have to leave because i
can't be massaged while my employees are
here can't do that
but do something that take some walks go
to the park walk your dog play with your
kids all of that stuff you don't need me
to tell it to you you get it already but
how about you stay off this thing for
the weekend you can play around on
locals if you want because we do other
fun stuff there involving food and music
and
joy and happiness and everything else
but just detox from some of it and i
think you'll find things a little bit
better and i will say one last thing
which is that if you dig what i do and
you're in the florida area in case you
forgot there's a couple seats left june
2nd i am going to be with the governor
who's doing it right and that's why
things are so good here that's why viva
fry is moving here from canada do we
have the image of me and we don't have
it today all right that's all right that
ron desantis guy and me are going to be
at the plaza live in orlando on june 2nd
and vip is sold out but there are a
couple seats left you can go to
davereuben.com
events happy friday everybody uh enjoy
the weekend we'll do it again on monday
thank you
and audios